what's going on guys this is rob and
nathaniel is one of our largest
contributors on patreon specifically
he's part of the honor guard and as part
of the honor guard you get to request
your own beyond omega level video and
nathaniel requested parallax so we are
going to do beyond omega level parallax
now originally parallax was created by
ron mars and daryl banks and first
appeared in green lantern number 48 in
1994. now this version of parallax came
onto the scene in the midst of dc's
attempt to breathe new life into the
green lantern franchise by replacing hal
jordan who had basically been the green
lantern for nearly 40 years and they
sought to do this by replacing him with
a character named kyle raynor so after
hal's hometown of coast city is
destroyed by a super villain known as
mongol he basically goes crazy and then
kills all the green lantern cores and
becomes a super villain that calls
himself parallax now there is a little
more to this than that initially it
wasn't him just losing his mind and
going nuts i guess it kind of was but he
actually recreated the whole city and
the people in it using his green lantern
ring which was a violation of the green
lantern's policy and then he was
basically chastised for it and then
that's when he went crazy and started
calling himself parallax and so this
basically was the original concept of
the character of parallax to be an evil
version of hal jordan but when jeff
johns took over green lantern he
basically changed the character into an
ancient parasite that had been around
since the beginning of time when the
emotional spectrum was created now over
time each aspect of the emotional
spectrum gained sentience and spawned an
entity to embody it and these entities
each corresponded to a color which in
turn corresponds to one of the emotions
along the emotional spectrum so the
version of parallax introduced when jeff
johns literally reinvented the green
lantern mythos was basically the avatar
of the yellow portion of the emotional
spectrum and the physical manifestation
of fear throughout the universe and so
parallax we would learn came about when
the first insects found themselves
threatened by the first land-dwelling
animals after they evolved from the sea
creatures and therefore felt fear for
the very first time now the first insect
to actually feel fear would later on
become parallax but many years later he
would be captured by the guardians of
the universe and imprisoned for billions
of years within the central power
battery on owa a fact that the guardians
of the universe would keep secret out of
fear that someone would find out about
parallax and then try to free him and so
this is something we refer to as
foreshadowing we also found out during
this time that parallax which came to be
referred to as the yellow impurity was
responsible for the traditional weakness
of the green lantern core against the
color yellow which made a lot more sense
than just the idea that that specific
color would be immune to the power of
the green lantern ring which was
literally the idea back in like the 40s
and 50s it's just the color yellow so
presumably you could run up on the green
lantern with like a crayola crayon and
then stab him in the face and that's the
end of the green lantern
but once sinestro a former green lantern
that had betrayed the core and obtained
a yellow power ring from a planet called
cord that exists in the antimatter
universe once he was also imprisoned on
oah parallax was awakened and then
eventually freed from its confinement
and it would actually be this entity
that would influence hal jordan to turn
into a super villain now while possessed
by parallax how was able to cause the
entire justice league teen titans and
the justice society to basically become
crippled with fear and was only stopped
when the spirit of vengeance which had
once inhabited the specter separated the
entity which actually led to hal jordan
becoming the spectre for a while but
needing a new host parallax sought out
and possessed gampin one of the
guardians of the universe which is a
testament to just how powerful this guy
is it took the combined forces of five
green lanterns to remove parallax from
ganton and then return it to its prison
on owa now as for his powers parallax's
primary ability is that he can cause
others to feel immense fear to the point
that he can actually control their minds
and he has at various times controlled
beings as powerful as wonder woman
superman and even the spectre which is
widely regarded as the second most
powerful entity in the dc universe below
only the presence the dc universe's
supreme being basically got and
according to the specter parallax's
ability to instill fear in others is so
great that it caused entire
civilizations to collapse because
everybody was so paranoid now parallax
is also able to amp the power level of
any host he possesses and since this
ability is based on its ability to draw
on fear the level to which parallax can
increase its house powers is
theoretically limitless since there's
always an abundance of fear in the
universe now like members of the
sinestro corps or the yellow lantern
corps if you want to call on that
parallax can create hard light
constructs that are incredibly strong
and because parallax is a being of pure
energy it's impossible to deal physical
damage to the entity itself now parallax
is so powerful that during the time when
he was possessing hal jordan he had
designs on actually remaking the entire
universe and this took place during an
event known as zero hour crisis in time
which as you may have gathered from the
name was one of several crises that dc's
done throughout their history that are
actually used to reboot all or part of
the dc universe regardless this event
starts off with a villain called x-stand
which is actually hawk from hawk and
duff who we assume is the main villain
of the story now extant had gained
control over time and the entire
timeline of the dc universe was
basically coming apart but during the
course of the story we find out that the
one who's controlling things is actually
hal jordan under the influence of
parallax who's basically trying to
rewrite the timeline so that coast city
was never destroyed but we learned that
this is all just a small part of
parallax's plan as he reveals that
following his first encounter with the
other green lanterns that ended in his
defeat he realized he actually wanted to
remake the entire universe so to achieve
this he enters the time stream and
absorbs the chronal energy that was left
over from the first crisis on infinite
earth which makes him powerful enough to
seemingly erase almost everything in
existence in fact the superheroes that
survive indicate that he's responsible
for billions of deaths so it seems that
for a time at least he was actually able
to bring an end to almost everything in
existence now parallax informs the
heroes that he wants to create a more
perfect universe one free of all the
consequences of the shortcomings all of
them had had over the years and although
he is eventually defeated it takes the
combined forces of some of dc's most
powerful heroes including superman
captain adam dr fate two green lanterns
and even the spectre to defeat this guy
so that fact alone places parallax well
beyond omega level which isn't
surprising because any time dc sets up
one of its crisis events we can pretty
much be sure that whoever the big bad of
that event happens to be is going to be
extremely powerful because they threaten
the existence of the entire universe and
parallax really came close to destroying
a universe and remaking it according to
his own will i mean technically he did
blink it out of existence and then bring
it back which is kind of how they use
zero hour to fix a lot of the problems
from crisis uninvited earth but
regardless he's definitely one of the
most powerful beings in the dc universe
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
again nathaniel for being a member of
the honor guard on patreon and i will
catch you all later
peace